fifteen percent or more.
>> Laura: A LESBIAN COUPLE IS
SUING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND THE U.S. CONFERENCE OF
CATHOLIC BISHOPS ASKED HER THEY
WERE DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME FOSTER PARENTS TO AN
UNACCOMPANIED REFUGEE CHILD.
THE WOMEN CLAIMED THEY WERE
UNLAWFULLY TURNED DOWN FOR
RELIGIOUS REASONS BECAUSE THE
TEXAS PROGRAM TAKES FEDERAL
MONEY.
JOINING US NOW FROM NEW YORK TO
DISCUSS THE SITUATION IS FROM
THE CATHOLIC LEAGUE,
PRESIDENT BILL DONOHUE.
PHIL, WHAT’S GOING ON IN THIS
CASE?
THIS COUPLE SAYS THEY WERE TOLD
BASICALLY THEY ARE NOT -- THERE
COUPLE-DOM IS NOT MIRRORING THAT
OF THE HOLY FAMILY, WHICH IS
WHAT THE CATHOLIC ORGANIZATION
TOLD THEM.
>> THERE WAS ONE ALLEGATION, ONE
WOMAN DENIED THAT.
THIS IS A PATTERN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
ACLU SUING CATHOLIC HOSPITALS TO
MAKE THEM PERFORM ABORTIONS.
YOU HAVE GAY TRYING TO CRASH
CATHOLIC INSTITUTIONS, FOSTER
CARE OR WHATEVER IT IS.
THEY’VE LOST EVERY SINGLE TIME.
IN THE CASE OF THIS CASE IN
TEXAS, A LAW WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR DETECTING THE RIGHT OF
FAITH-BASED INITIATIVES TO
EXERCISE THEIR DOCTRINAL
PREROGATIVES.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE CATHOLIC
AGENCIES WHICH DO NOT BELIEVE IN
SAME-SEX MARRIAGES DO NOT HAVE
TO ALLOW A LESBIAN COUPLE TO
HAVE THEIR CARE.
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE HAVE
FAITH-BASED INSTITUTIONS FOR
DECADES.
JUST AS LONG AS YOU DON’T
INVOLVE YOURSELF IN A INHERENTLY
RELIGIOUS ACTIVITIES.
SUCH AS FORCING THE KIDS TO GO
TO MASS AND PRAYER SERVICES,
THINGS THAT WOULD MAKE SOME
PEOPLE NERVOUS, PEOPLE HAVE A
PHOBIA ABOUT RELIGION, THEN YOU
ARE OKAY.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO
LOSE, IT’S A MATTER OF BULLYING
AND HARASSMENT IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: PRESUMABLY THIS
COUPLE IF THEY WANTED TO FOSTER
A CHILD, THERE’S PROBABLY NO
SHORTAGE OF CHILDREN IN THE
UNITED STATES, OR CERTAINLY IN
TEXAS I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THEY
COULD PROBABLY FIND THAT THEY
WOULD BE WELCOME TO FOSTER THESE
CHILDREN.
YOUR POINT IS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO THESE VARIOUS CATHOLIC
ORGANIZATIONS -- GO >> THEY ARE
SHOPPING THEM.
THE ACLU IN PARTICULAR IS DOING
THIS.
THESE ARE ACTIVISTS, THEY TRY TO
ACT AS IF THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHOVE THEIR
SECULAR VALUES DOWN OUR THROAT.
IT’S WHERE THE CHURCH GETS TOO
AGGRESSIVE.
WE SAY WHAT ABOUT CHURCH AND
STATE.
IT WORKS THE OTHER WAY MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT.
WHEN THE STATE IS ENCROACHING ON
A RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION, WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE THESE RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY PROTECTION LAWS ALL OVER
THE STATES.
IT’S PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
SECULAR MILITANTS TRYING TO
SHOVE THEIR WAY IN AND TO
BASICALLY NEUTER CATHOLIC
INSTITUTIONS.
ONCE YOU TAKE OUT THE
CATHOLICITY OF A CATHOLIC
INSTITUTION, IT’S NOW SECULAR.
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS.
>> Laura: THE LUTHERANS DO A
LOT.
>> I’M SURE THE UNITARIANS WOULD
LOVE THEM.
>> Laura: THEY LUTHERANS DO A
LOT OF RESETTLEMENT AS WELL.
IF THEY GET A BIG FEDERAL GRANT.
THAT’S ALSO AN ISSUE.
IN MASSACHUSETTS, THEY BASICALLY
DID AWAY WITH CATHOLIC
ADOPTIONS, CORRECT?
AND IN OTHER STATES, CATHOLIC
ADOPTION AGENCIES ARE BASICALLY
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF THESE
LAWSUITS, CORRECT?
>> IT VARIES BY STATE AND SOME
STATES THE CATHOLICS HAVE BEEN
WILLING TO CAPITULATE.
THIS IS NOT A SETTLED ISSUE, BUT
IF ANYTHING, THE LAW IS ON OUR
SIDE, PARTICULARLY WITH THE
STATES THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS THERE.
WE’VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS FOR A
LONG TIME.
WHY ISN’T THE CATHOLIC HOSTILE
CONTINUING NOT TO PERFORM
ABORTIONS?
WHY IS IT THAT ADOPTION AGENCIES
CONTINUE TO INSIST ON CATHOLIC
DOCTRINES?
A FEDERAL OR LAW.
WHAT YOU HAVE YOUR IS THE INTENT
IS TO INTIMIDATE, TO BULLY, TO
GET THEM TO CAPITULATE SO IF YOU
GET -- MASSACHUSETTS IS NOT
KNOWN FOR THEIR STRONG CATHOLIC
OPINIONS.
>> Laura: WE WILL HEAR IT FROM
THOSE CATHOLICS IN MASSACHUSETTS